yes we did cuz we back at it again it's
the fighter in the kid this is really
the fighter in the kid come on baby all
right you ready chin let's do this man
let's do it yeah I got to get back to
the shop man what do you mean my hands
smell like smell that you're always in
the shop now I know dude yeah right I
get it dude I got my own shop now dude
yeah you got a little wound on your arm
too it looks like it's infected that
wound looks like it's you know what it's
doing it being traumatic it's seeping
that wound is seeping and Son's mouth
open still open right now I can't see it
that looks like it's seeping that
doesn't look good yeah oh yeah I thought
you were joking really you look like
you're about to get gang green we're
going to have to Lop it off right at the
old right at the old short sleeve we're
going to give you a short SLE I come on
Monday I'm like what's up everybody
Brian was right and that's when you get
it you lose it up to GRE in my arm
uh-huh not good not fun well that's what
happens when you now since you're
talking about the shop I'm probably
going to have to bother you now I got to
get back to my shop dude I'm feeling I
got get back to my shop you got to get
bad your shop I do I got some work to do
we're installing the the supercharger
the wheel you're doing more for the
truck this for the lightning different
truck the other trucks out of commission
which I'll be able to talk about once
Insurance gets other truck other truck
might be in the hospital right now
getting just other truck might be six
feet under and I probably should have
been six feet under yeah you saw the
video I saw the video yeah it's what
happens though you know it's what
happens I feel like insurance will be
like yeah you got you have a claim
though I I talked this morning we're
good yeah um now 2024 now I'm feeling uh
I'm a little sore in the in the Trap
region my from Su and [__] no from
driving Tesla no I got from tensing up
just about life cuz you're so soft might
taken a Jiu-Jitsu class yesterday might
have taken an MMA class yesterday yeah
yeah I know you know what I you know you
know how I know you don't know how to
fight when you told me you took get MMA
class well it was a little it was a
little striking little Jiu-Jitsu little
little wrestling
now um where at well I'm glad you asked
uh it's in a in a fantastic Place uh
called no no MMA No No's MMA no no yeah
do you know no no I don't okay he uh his
son fights in Bellator who's his son uh
you know that's that's I'm you're being
pretty vague right now being vague but
awesome he gives a free class Tuesday
Thursdays just shows up because he used
to be in Ho's corner and he's got a lot
of guys under his belt but uh guy French
dude French for Legion yeah no no no o n
o yeah yeah yeah MMA he's awesome he's
awesome he you would love him you dude
you would no that's not yeah that's it
that's it he doesn't teach hito he
teaches wrestling and Jiu-Jitsu I don't
know sayoko on there oh no that's not
him that's not him different guy this
guy's 62 babba what city is this in uh
it's in uh that's the right
gyos go to their website Chen if you go
uh over what his website this one here
this hito though yeah that's
it he's always got he's got a ping got a
ping pong table in there a
giant it says website on
here Direction there it is right [__]
yeah dude hell my eyes suck oh damn it
and then he sells cactuses n can this is
the wrong guy this is all the wrong guy
well that was the right gym that gym see
that picture see photos go go up there
please no the other one please yeah
there you go no looks like a nice gym
yeah it's great it's right there it's
always closed uh he teaches kids and
it's all for free and he is you 12y olds
up or what I look at him and I go I'm
like well I'm in there with everybody's
21 everybody's 21 years old and I'm I'm
and old and I'm what a great gym it's
great and I'm 57 and I'm in there with
uh Sun be 57 and I'm there with a bunch
of 22y olds your birthday is January
26th damn it's coming up it's coming up
yeah I I'm yeah I'm I'm going to uh same
thing as usual same thing as I'm GNA do
nothing I'm GNA do nothing UH 60 is the
big one 60 we got to do something we got
to do something for my 50 if I'm still
here if I'm still here well 60 is only
three years away for you three years
away that's
insane um well his website doesn't work
so he looks at me and he goes uh I have
a disease I said what are you he's 62
couldn't look better full head of hair
must French was in the French Foreign
Legion probably south of France which is
uh a different thing kind of a tougher
tougher group um and looks at me and
goes I have a disease I said oh I was
like oh no what he goes He races
motorcycles and then one of his students
goes show him your car collection yeah
Bubba you would lose your mind there he
is some cool cars that's his son oh
that's his son Mir Costa Jean Gracie um
that's him right there that's him right
there oh he looks like me he's the best
he looks like he look like me at 50 he
is that's by the way he really does we
look ID that's a great call that is both
have the long hair now yep uh his kid
wrestled the Miracles was a like a some
unbelievable wrestler now he's in what's
his car collection what what's where he
get his money from oh his I don't know
his car collection though there's
there's his son stud boy me and this guy
need to become friends yeah dude he
that's what he put out that's his son
right there that's what he created so
you know you can tell his family his
family is his life you can see it yeah
and uh and then he shows me his car
collection you would have lost your mind
he's got the old vintage Ferraris like a
whole row of them real vintage vintage
um Mercedes Benz I mean I was like
vintage F I mean you're not touching one
for under seven figures D oh dude I
wonder where he's getting it looked like
a museum and then and then so then when
he's not racing motorcycles he's got
those cars and then he goes and then
that's his disease that and chocolate he
he eats chocolate that was it I was like
love thisy besides chocolate and he's
he's hilarious awesome he's hilarious
and I go in there and and he's hitting
me with it I'm the older man so you know
you think he goes wrong give me 10
push-ups he's just messing with me I'm
like what and count I'm like was it ghee
or no ghee no ghee he he teaches kids
with ghee uh but should learn well
that's we just learn stuff and you know
it's great and are you going to go back
I'm going to go back I'll be there every
Tuesday Thursday that' be good at 4 and
I love it yeah it's fun it's fun it's
been a long time is there somebody your
age there isn't there isn't anybody my
age bu that's a bummer yeah there're a
bunch of young you're like the big guy
like big guys is tough for us to find
sparring partners yeah for old guys same
thing Daddy's in some shape though daddy
will D daddy will hang might get hurt
you know who will box you and box your
stupid face off who Jan Jan boxes my my
uh CPA Jan boxes he has a fight coming
up in Vegas the how much you love him
for that nuts he's got to be 70
something he's like he's like b i I got
to cut 15 lbs by the 28th I'm like for
what he's like my fight that's
unbelievable like all right as he's
eating pizza well God bless him that's
crazy yeah getting getting hit I stopped
uh sparring when you said I said I'm
dizzy yeah and you said this is not good
for you at your age and I said oh I'm
not going to do that anymore yeah
there's no yeah you don't need to spar
you look at me you look back and you
keep it up no it's terrible remember
when you told me to come to a wild card
see how that works out for me yep yep
terrible idea but Jiu-Jitsu you can Spar
full full board you're nothing bad
you're going with a bad partner I kind
know I can't keep my you know just stay
in a ball just kind don't get crazy a
good enough guy [__] you up but yeah
sure yeah but if you're rolling with
like other like blue purple they know
what they're doing yeah yeah you just do
your thing be nice get another 56y old
and tussle with you be nice you can it's
tough to get 56 year olds in there it is
it is you could teach me some stuff and
I go in there and you know kind of you
know what I mean little little details I
wish you lived closer I know cuz I would
go there I know would you roll a little
bit oh yeah yeah that would love to so
much fun' be fun for you to be in there
yeah that'd be fun just bigger than
everybody else well cuz they're all
they're all guys my size they're all
like athletic young uh 21 year olds but
they're all you know no bigger than me
so some of them are a little thicker but
that's cool yeah you just walk in and
start [__] suplexing guys no man I
don't want that let's go
I don't want that I miss it though I do
miss I feel it feels good just about it
Miss yeah I miss it yeah but it's it's
it's at least an hour and a half your
day it's a commitment yeah you got kids
and you got it's a commitment yeah it's
a lot it's a lot now if I was if I had a
lot of
money I would probably shut everything
down and just do that yeah and practice
for five hours then get injured and then
not do it anymore do you know what I'm
saying though true right so Gordon Ryan
uh hit that uh
do you see his post no his stomach is so
bad he has to just stop I think he had
to have his T tonsils and part of his
intestines removed God I love that guy
too he such a bummer
um you know a lot of guys he spars a lot
of high level boxers I believe that you
talking about Strickland yeah so Brian
for you just listening this G be random
as [__] but Strickland says he spars a
lot of high level boxers and they'll ask
him why he doesn't box and he says maybe
I one day I will for a Mone fight
absolutely you tell me Strickland versus
Jake Paul wouldn't make all the money oh
my God I don't think Jake Paul wants
that smoke but he he would do it he
would do it he' do it yeah Jake Paul
would fight any MMA guy including uh
Sean strickman 100% he'd do it that'd be
pretty I'd love to watch that actually
problem problem UFC would they would the
UFC allow him to yeah do the Conor
McGregor thing and become a bigger star
yeah oh that's true they might do if
they thought he'd beat him but this is
such a bummer for him but you said
brenon that um the UFC let mazal and
Nate Diaz but they're not active like
remember Sean Strickland's a current
active champion and arguably the biggest
star in the UFC right now the most
popular so what they let that I mean
they did with Connor but his star got so
big they couldn't control him so I don't
think they ever let it happen again
unfortunately that was the bad thing of
them letting Connor do the Floyd fight
it's never happened again cuz he got too
famous and they don't have control over
him which they don't want he had to be
on antibiotics for 45 days this is
Gordon Ryan you you how bad that is for
you to clear a simple strap throat
infection which then colonized in my
tonsils also have strap and staff in my
intestines needing them to be removed it
took me 6 months to recover from that
camp what I went through these last few
weeks wasn't fun I was bedridden for
weeks without eating stomach full with
bile spending three to four days uh
hours a day belching and dry heaving in
the bathroom this poor guy horrible
while living that I finally accepted and
came to peace with the fact that my body
can't handle the amount of pressure I
put it under until my stomach and immune
system is 100% better he's one of those
extreme winners who just you know
obviously pushes himself you know him at
all I know him a little bit I don't such
a good guy I know I mean anybody who's
that great at something you know he's
just me they're good guys yeah yeah not
at all but he's a good guy yeah he's a
elite elite and he's a great person he's
got to step away what cracks me up is
how many people give that guy like how
many haters how many people give him
well that's what he wants though that's
why he's so big it's like hilarious no
but when when he I asked him when he did
food truck I said you know how do you
deal with the he goes well when I first
started Jiu-Jitsu I'd get hate no matter
what and then I was like I'm going to
lean into this he it's fun me so he just
fires back at it that's how you got so
big but it just so happens he's the best
ever do it so it worked out so you guys
are you're hating on the best that ever
do it you know how hard it is to be him
you know how hard it is to get to be to
be that good at at something hard but
they know this you're falling for it
it's hilarious they know that that's why
that's why it's fun for them like they
know he's great and they know he's going
to fire back and even look he put He put
I can be at peace he goes um uh I will
only be competing at ADCC until my
health is 100% restored and if not all
good no one will ever do what I've done
so I can be at peace with that like it's
that's his way you know that's what he
does love it he's the best love it the
absolute best fear no one Dana White was
active chin mhm Super Active we finally
got here's my question for you guys so
if you don't know Brian you still think
the the Chargers play in San Diego
that's fine but when it comes to this uh
so UFC 300 hasn't had like a marquee
fight we're expecting big fights there's
going to be another one coming but he
announced that Justin gatei and uh our
boy Max Holloway are fighting for the
BMF BMF stands for bad mother trucker
title yep does that would that get you
by 300 does that do it for you is that a
marquee fight for that gets me excited
um it's not knock your dick in the
ground exciting though is it not really
I'll tell you why it's really fun I tell
you they're both going to stand and bang
they're gonna they're going to be
throwing their hands a lot you're going
to see a like a oh there's no wrestling
no there's no wrestling no the match
Up's fantastic I would say Justin's
stronger this why it's a bummer we Max
hasn't had a lot of success at 55 he's
he's he's made for 45 he doesn't hit
hard enough at he's fighting guy who hit
hard when he fought Dustin porier
although he had some success he's just
not big enough to do damage so then you
see him get hurt yes you think he's
going to be okay against Justin
gatei I was like oh that's fun I love
Max yeah yeah but it's two huge names so
you can see why the UFC did it but this
isn't the fight like in 300 people are
going to you know all sorts of [__] cuz
not 200 100 but if you really look at
300 even though it's not the fights that
you're expecting it from top to bottom
that card is stacked it's not as good as
299 still but 300 is stacked and there's
one more fight they're going to announce
because there's there's three there's
usually three title fights so you have
the bmfl BMF title you have the waye uh
championship fight and there's going be
one more big dog I think it's going be
uh the winner of Strickland dupes
against uh Izzy that's what I think
they're waiting on uh uh oh really yeah
that's what I think but what do I know
against who I'm sorry so the winner of
uh DDP and Strickland will fight uh Izzy
is he's gonna come back that's what I
think he's gonna be cage
side that's what I think and it's in
June so it's enough time do we know what
his health issue was he had he had he
said something about no he just want to
take time off okay yeah yeah he's needed
a break he said three years but the UFC
is probably backing up the brink trucks
to get him back in there Cody garbrandt
fighting uh Davis great fight all those
are great B nickoll who is Cody Brundage
he's a tough character he's good but I
think the reason why that's a bit of a
bummer is you want you'd want UFC 300 to
be B Nichol's coming out party meaning
he's fighting a top 15 guy they're still
just slowly moving along I think it's on
purpose cuz the middleweight division is
such a cluster [__] they don't need the
fans vying for him for a title shot CU
everyone thinks he can fight for a title
right now so they're just holding him
back
let them figure that let the dust settle
and then we'll let you off the leash so
they get one
more well now they also got Jim Miller
Bobby green how cool is this Jim Miller
fought at UFC 100 fought at UFC 200 now
he's fighting right back to back UFC 300
he is he is and he's fighting at Bobby
green fights at 55 yes and Jim's
fighting at 55 then this is a 55 pounder
they're both they only fight so so um
Jim Miller has been fighting yeah
forever here's the thing he how many
fights he need to have 50 UFC fights
he'll be the first one ever to get to 50
UFC fights that's that is a rugged
character that's a rugged character what
do you think of uh now is he here the
question here who knows who gives a [__]
no I was gon to ask you if you think
he's gonna fight Brock Lesnar after that
oh that's so stupid no but uh the thing
is here's my question is Jim Miller UFC
Hall of Famer B let's take a little
break talking about UFC Hall of Fame
because there's some Hall of Famers
going down this weekend is there it's up
for a debate but U 297 is bringing a
stacked fight that's a loose term it's
not stacked with the main events fun
it's happening in Toronto so throw down
on the action with draftking Sportsbook
the official sports betting partner the
UFC will take your excitement level
north of the Border new customers can
bet five bucks and get 200 instantly in
bonus bets as far as odds go I like
Strickland o over the rounds I think
it's four and a half I think Strickland
gets it done by decision or by TKO late
in the round so it's decent bet there
download the draftking sports spec at SP
Sportsbook app with code fighter new
customers can uh bet just five bucks on
UFC 297 and get 200 instant in bonus
bets only on draftking Sportsbook with
the code Fighter the crown is yours
gambling problem call 1 800 Gambler or
visit www.1 18800 gambler. net in New
York call
8778 heny or text Hope NY
46739 in Connecticut help is available
for problem gambling call
8887895118 77 or visit
cpg.io in Ontario bonus bets expire 168
hours after issuance see
dk.com MMA for eligibility and deposit
restrictions terms and responsible
gaming resources listen guys head over
to partner. houseof macadamias Doc TFK
I'll say it again head over to
partner. houseof macadamias
docf now let me tell you why we we
talking about nuts baby we talking about
the best tasting nuts on the planet
which are also super good for you we
love nuts we love them subscribe your to
your favorite bundle get free snack bars
every time with 15% off the whole order
plus certain bundles come with bonus
goodies like free Macadamia milk you can
put your coffee that's super healthy you
get the chocolate cover macam which we
always eat the % macadamia nut bars but
the best for me for snacking is the
chocolate covered macadamia nut and
change up your macademia subscription at
any stage no strings attached uh you can
pause you can cancel at any time so all
you got to do to get the best nuts of
your life macademia nuts not just for
the rich anymore go to partner. housam
academia.com
TFA House of academias enjoy enjoy um I
have to I have to put him in the Hall of
Fame just for for longevity at that
levity you know just for how many wins
does he have says I mean he's bought 43
times you have to put so he'll never get
50 fights in the UFC but he'll get 50
fights overall he's at 43 this will be
44 so he has six more fights in the UFC
let me ask you so if he gets to third
but 30 fights in the
UFC fight three times a year 10 year
reign fighting three times a year is
nuts it's
insane Cal he's Cal Ripken of the UFC
yeah butal rip R far almost you know
it's like somebody who's that rugged who
can just take that kind of punishment
over and over I I I um oh damn DC
doesn't claims he doesn't deserve a spot
in the Hall of Fame well the longer
question is like with a lot of other
sports you have Journeymen you have guys
that have been there for you've got
plenty of guys in the NFL played for 18
years they're not in the Hall of Fame
they're not in the Hall of Fame but NFL
NBA is not the UFC that's what I'm
saying big difference big difference big
difference big big difference you really
could make the argument it's just so
hard to stay injury free it's so hard to
stay you know to train on that level how
many can I see Jim Miller's
record you know he's still winning uh
dude he's won five of his last six I
mean now he's not fighting like World
beaters but why why don't they do this
do this to Tony Ferguson man they've
tossed him to the goddamn Wolverines
dude I know I know but for Jim Miller
they've been cool with it yeah I mean
the last time he fought a ranked guy
keep going
downt Charles Charles and he lost Dan
hook Dan hooker Anthony some of the guys
he lost a lot of the guys that are he
beat theago alvz beat Joe louo on beat G
lost Diego Sanchez lost to Michael Denny
Castillo was tough lost to Donald YY
Mandel was a beast back in the day Pat
Healey no contest beat Joe luo on lost
to Nate Diaz beat Melvin G lost to
Ben um beat Charles Ola that's crazy
beat gleon tyau Jesus G SE tyout in in
when he's not cutting he's [__] huge
for sure beat M danzing beat Dwayne
Ludwig beat Matt Wyman damn look at how
back how far back he goes lost to Grey
Manor look man he's he's taking on all
commers I mean one two three well keep
going down CH let me see his first
debut was in 20 5 oh that's so nuts
that's so [__] CRA so if he if he
fights two more years dude you're
fighting for 21 years that's insane how
many so he's lost one keep going he's
lost one well you can go up it give
total it'll give total you don't need to
go
yeah uh and he's only been knocked out
twice out of out of all the all all the
was he was that four what do he say how
many 43 I think it was see that's
significant too he's only been knocked
out twice all that time well no hold on
out of 43 fights he's only been finished
five times that's insane nuts that's
that's [__] insane and remember 55 is
also the deepest division so you're
fighting the most talented guys the most
talented they're good at everything cuz
if if you have 50 fights in the
heavyweight you're fighting some c i I
would say this I think what Jim Miller
has is so hard so hard and he's still
doing it and he and so yeah what he's
doing is than what rip in I agree age
not even remotely close no I agree you
you got to give it up you got to give it
up I you got you got to remember that
that's such an significant thing to
fight 43 times against all these guys
you've got knocked out you got caught
twice also also remember has never
missed weight that's insane so that's
another so can Cal Ripken cut weight and
make every time yeah but he's only like
to your point he's only not been able to
finish the fight five times that's huge
nuts that's so hard fighting the best of
the best and you know any guy how old is
he CU any guy who's been doing it so
long you have 55 where speed and
reaction time is everything exactly 40
he's 40 in a division where speed and
reaction time is everything he's he's
still stayed safe he's still winning
that's insane go down Jen it says mixed
martial arts record 55 fights I mean
amate as well come on dude give it up
you got to put him in the Hall of Fame
you got got him you got him 55 fights
has only been finished five times he's a
whole Famer yeah you got it yeah I mean
that's I'm surprised DC was so tough on
him but you got remember DC DC's a lead
I think DC's arguing about the whole
Championship thing cuz Miller Denver won
a championship but he but there's guys
in the other Pro Sport never won
championships there should be a wing for
hard it is to win a championship in the
UFC yeah if if if that it's dictated off
just being a champion then you're not
having a big very big big [__] Fame
Miller did talk about DC he said like uh
I have the same record as D DC he only
fought like I guess what a certain
amount of times he goes yeah I've I had
the exact same record as DC and I'm I'm
I'm doubling it tripling it as he's you
know continuing to fight on D is a lead
Elite I mean I I always he's to me the
most impressive fighter in what he was
dealing with like tools wise and just a
two-time Olympian I mean he's just so
special but I I think DC is using the
the the criteria that other sports would
use but this is different no no no
that's a terrible argument other sports
if they just put in guys that won MVP or
super bows you're having a small [__]
group that's stupid idea so you want to
put Dan Marino in the Hall of Fame you
got to put him in the Hall of Fame never
won a Super Bowl that's
right uh he's a Hall of Famer in my book
for without a
doubt I mean you know that is surprising
I I I would make the argument he Don
srone would you put him in Hall of Fame
100% okay now hold on but Donald was
never Champion but Donald also I think
held the record for a while for a long
while of the most wins in the UFC so
that's a lot but then again he also
fought a lot Jim Miller has more wins
you got to give it up now now you could
also make the argument did Donald Donald
fought for titles you know Donald was up
there always in the top Donal was always
top 10 yeah Jim Miller yeah so hold on
the guy who has the most total fights
also the most total wins by a good
amount C's only three off but still
rovski that's crazy rovski number two
interesting I never would have got guess
that ever Donal C I beat Hall of Famer
um here and well if you just go go up
chin every single guy in the winds
column is in the hall of fame or lski
is's Hall of Famer the only guy who's
not a Hall of Famer is Neil
Magny but every other single guy on that
list including total fights is a Hall of
Famer yeah
you're gonna have how about Klay Gua
you're gonna have these conversations
some guys are are
supering Jim Mill is a shoeing I I think
it's an easy Sho I don't think it's a
debate do you think he gets in
100% And there's certain Wings it
doesn't have to be like you know
straight up Hall of Famer no no no no no
don't do him like that but there are
wings there are wings no [__] the wings
he should be a Bonafide Hall of Famer
that's insane what are we talking about
yeah um yeah longevities notos and at 55
the deepest division in all
organizations in all over the world
there's more dudes walk around at 55 and
160 170 who can make 55 than any other
weight class in the world and he has
there is a question of what what is his
highest rank what's the highest rank
he's ever
held they didn't have rankings when he
was at his prime um look at the current
that's a tough well you don't want to
look at the current ones he's not
currently ranked that' be a waste of
your time but time he was ranked but the
argument would be when he was in his
Prime when he's beating those guys we
mentioned Charles Ola some of those
other dudes uh Weidman there was no
ranking
system um well says here currently
number 52
yeah I do think you have to take rank
into account even you know you know what
I'm saying uh Daniel Cormier was never
under under three rank three uh that's a
ter argument cuz when he was in his
prime so would you keep DC out of Hall
of Fame with there's no rankings when he
was fighting there's no ranking D never
lost he only lost twice to well he lost
to Stipe later on and he lost lost to
John knocked out that's it as a
heavyweight is basically undefeated
until he fought Stipe and beat stpe the
first time so you know you can't compare
Daniel Cormier to Jim Miller you are I'm
not no no no that's a bad argument no
why why would you well yeah but but but
but I don't think anybody is but we're
talking about Hall of Fame so so my
question to you is if you are going to
take it does longevity which should play
a factor how much of a factor ises
longevity play in in relation to ranking
in terms of how long were you in the top
10 were you ever in the top 10 were you
you can do that for guys when the
ranking started right when Jim Miller
was in his prime there's no ranking
system so why would you hold that
against you could you could but you
could I'll tell you how because you
could also then say when he was in his
prime who who did he fight that was in
the top Charles ol is he wasn't back
then he was losing a lot so you going to
hold that against him because he world
champion yes but that was he was a young
fighter he didn't have that none of that
matters though back still has a win do
it he still has a win over him but but
but he when he beat him Charles Olivera
wasn't ranked right that's the problem
is that you do have to look at who he
fought that does play a large but again
B back when he fought him nobody was
ranked there was no ranking system okay
let me ask you that's my
argument the guys he fought they were in
the top 10 he lost every February 2013
is when uh the rankings started for the
UFC what say February 2013 was when the
rankings started with UFC all right um
let's see
here that's that's a long time that's 10
years ago and so Jim Miller did fight
during that time y but my argument is
he's wasn't in his prime when he was in
his prime there was no official 10 years
ago when he's 30 that's his prime no not
55 well then when was he at CU when he
was in so 2013 he was in his prime when
he went on a uh let's see here 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 11 he went he went out of
when he was in his prime he won 10
fights out of 11 beating the likes of
Charles Ola gleon Tabo uh uh that Mark
uh bosec is no punk Dwayne lugwig was no
punk M danzing no punk gray mayard Matt
Wyman Melvin is a [__] rough dude so
um so when you're smaller weight your
your Prime's about and your your your
20s your mid 20s and then it it falls
off you know now older guys have a
longer Prime but 55 year Prime's not
that long that's why again another
feather in his cap to be that relevant
for so long at 55 when your Prime should
be way past you he deserves to be in the
Hall of
Fame
uh I can see I can see both arguments
knowing me I'm I'm leaning on I'm
leaning toward you and I'm going to give
him the Hall of Fame nod also the only
guy to fight in UFC 100 200 and 300 yep
there's a I I I I would make an argument
I I can make an argument for both sides
I'm gonna put him in jimiller out of
respect I got put him in if you don't
let Jim Miller in you're not letting in
a lot of guys then yeah then there's
like 10 guys but let's let's make a good
comparison him and Donald seron Donald
Cerrone had his his losses but Donald
Cerrone fought all comers and beat a lot
of great guys you know so and I think
always ranked and the top five typically
for long stretches so plus Donald was a
WC Champion right yeah Donald's 40 now
[__]
crazy Love It Go his actual record here
no let me see Donald has a [__] ton of
fights too but all right he obviously
the
OB Prime 36 wins 17 losses very similar
right 55 look at this so it's very
similar it's a very good comparison uh
let's let's find his best win out eight
times let's find his best win hold
on find his best win better than better
than Jim Miller's win over Charles
Olivera well Matt Brown um Patrick cot
remember that fight Alex
Oliva um Ben Henderson unbelievable
miles jury Eddie Alvarez Eddie Alvarez
his best win Eddie Alvarez came in as
beat jimiller with a head kick yeah that
there's thats edar Barbosa monster
[__] monster so you're looking at
real JY Stevens especially then was a
monster he did beat Charles Olivera yeah
TKO twice twice uh Chris hardi was no
punk Jamie Varner back then was no
punk lost to Benson Henderson then came
back and beat Benson Henderson he lost
to Benson twice right and then came back
third
remember when he beat when he when he Lo
when he uh beat Jamie Varner it was uh
Varner took his uh championship belt oh
wow uh Rob McCulla was a badass in WC
yeah he's he fought a lot of bad
[__] and won lost some and came
back and won too strength of schedule is
not even comparable to I mean Cerrone
has such bigger wins I C's a first batt
at Hall of Fame he's in
the in the better and and lost to Jim
Miller and
that's kind of crazy last one yeah
um yeah Jim Miller's jiller choked him
out but then he in their Prime he KO
kicked Jim Miller in the
face yeah but then Jim Miller came back
and be yeah Donald Donald fought
probably five
fights um too long you know which he
would uh some would say eight Brian yeah
maybe he lost one two three four five
six seven yeah but having said that did
some [__] did some [__] in that ring
oh did some [__] I mean so it's a good
comparison uh he's definitely
in look ar you know I'm gonna go you
know I'm voting for Jim Miller be in
Hall of Fame I you know I'm gonna do
that just out of out of the I mean I
have DC on my show and I'd ask him I'd
say who else doesn't get in like what
what's your criteria who else doesn't
get
in yeah yeah does Brock Lesnar get get
in does Shane Carwin get in who didn't
have very long careers at all I don't
see that oh they're both Hall of Famers
Shane Carwin and and Brock Lesnar Brock
lindar for
sure yeah wow how much did he fight BB I
I I I can't do it I'm putting Jim Miller
in before I put those two guys in you're
not putting Brock heavyweight champion
of the
world zero experience for a little bit
he I don't think Frank his first fight
he beats Frank mayor of first bout Hall
of Famer he beats Frank mayor yeah Shane
Carwin beat Shane Carwin yeah beat Randy
Couture Hall of Famer beat some guys a
terrible some guys hold on though just
short career but the the NFL put in tra
Davis he only had I think four or five
year career but did work when he's there
five years but then then so so he was
when did he become a heavyweight
champion how many title times did he
defend his title Brock after Cain
Velasquez it was it was pretty much done
cuz he got beat by Kane I think uh and
then he got beat by over over but he
also had diverticulitis he was sick
there's a lot of [__] going on with him
F don't give a [__] about that he's also
older so let me see Mark hunt no contest
I don't know what that was about well no
he beat the sh Mar but then he you know
test so on let's just go through so this
man only had uh in the UFC he only had 1
2 3 4 five 6 seven eight fights yeah he
lost three of those eight so he has five
fights but his strength of schedule is
bananas his first fight was against
Frank may he lost got knard which is one
of my favorite fights of all time then
he fought Heath hering the Crazy Horse
no punk then he fought Randy Couture for
the heavyweight championship knocked him
out defended the belt against Frank May
knocked him out then submitted Shane
Carwin for the intern belt Shane had the
intern belt but then he gets dicey then
he fought Cain Velasquez gets beat up
Alro mobbed him up and then he ragd
dolled Mark hun at UFC 200 which is
crazy by the way Ragdoll Mar um yeah I
mean It's just tough one I can't I can't
Bubba really but Bubba can't do it hold
on but if you put Jim Miller in I want
to over but if you're putting
jiller that's right sir 55 times 43
times so this guy look at that resume
yeah I know dude yeah yeah can't do it
sorry yeah Hey listen and he was a lot
older when he fought absolutely he's a
he had a great time now listen listen
you have fun here's the thing all due
respect came in too late came in too
late he's a he's a he's a freak if he
had started when he was younger nobody
touches Brock Lesnar he's a monster but
uh I can't I can't little too late yeah
so that's a I'm glad I'm not on the
board because I I put Brock and Jim in
Jim put I'm trying to think who I
wouldn't put in well who don't you put
in let's talk about it I'm loving this
conversation because there's a this is
where we get into some crazy we get into
some crazy talk um okay Diego
Sanchez he's crazy yes Pioneer Pioneer
fighter won yeah but lost a lot won a
lot too though one a lot the most
exciting fights Max Holloway
100% that's yeah yeah other stupid ideas
no what I'm just saying let's go through
the OB the obvious ones are don't give
me don't give me obvious he's the
greatest one
F that's a good question never held a
belt that's a good question isn't it
held an interm belt but never held a
belt that's well he held an intern belt
that's not a belt that's not a real belt
UFC doesn't acknowledge it as a real
belt they don't pay you like you're DUS
P
100% okay Conor McGregor 100% come on
right um Izzy Izzy 100% but let's talk
Justin gatei cuz I'm [__] up right now
well Justin gatei multi multi-time world
champion World Series of fighting comes
to the UFC fought the who's who yeah
fought the who's who can I bring up
bring up G Justin Gate's record cuz we'd
have we'd we we'd have some problems oh
I I'll make the whole this whole show is
about who's in the Hall of Fame right
now well I got one for you after Justin
I got one for you yeah he's gonna it's
gonna hit you hard too see that's a
that's a win beat Dustin Justin gat you
beats Dustin poier yeah and he lost him
too Michael
Chandler I mean Tony Ferguson Donald
Cerrone Edson Barbosa
W Michael Johnson no
joke um well there's only wins there
there's only wins well that's World
Series of fighting but then when he went
to the go go up chin cuz in the UFC his
record is he's uh one two 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 so he's won eight lost four is
that a Hall of Fame rese lost eight I'm
sorry W eight lost four I can't oh
Justin gas on Hall of Fame I love Justin
G well you're a stickler I like this
want from me I can't it's the Hall of
Fame we're not [__] around pu yeah to
now to keep the same energy because if
you know that Brock Lesnar with his
resume who's an actual champ you can't
let Justin G in now Justin's not done
though so what if Justin beats Max
hallway for the bmfl title I'm still
having a
problem you know what I'm saying even if
you beat the Hall of Famer Max I I I you
know I don't know what to tell you cuz
Justin's beat look uh one of has to be
rare air khabib Nur Tony Ferguson Hall
of Famer Donald Hall of Famer Barosa
probably not James Vick no no that's it
no there are a lot of guys I can't ready
for this what what about our boy Luke
rockold I'm bring up his resume Strike
Force champ L Luke rockold UFC CH UFC
champ he was a UFC
champ and you're stickler yeah I I this
is this is I'm not this I'm not voting
because I'm I have an emotional
attachment so he beat Chris Weidman leoa
Macho Michael bisbing Tim Boch custo
philipo monster monster lost to vtor
beat our boy Tim Kennedy yeah but lost
to
VOR beat joare that's in strike for us
but still Jesse Taylor he's a Hall of
Famer he's a Hall of Famer he's Hall of
Famer Luke rockold a Hall of Famer Luke
rockold is a Hall of Famer he's a Hall
of Famer you got to put him in
dude beat leot Mach yeah in his prime
bisbing yes Tim Bo I still maintain had
been acclimated to that that that
altitude which he he got there three
days before be he beats uh Pao Costa I
don't know about that he he should I
didn't think he looked great neither one
of them looked great yeah he's just too
tired but he he does um he got tired of
training he got tired of fighting heed
isn't that weird combo to have though
Hall of Fame combo cuz guys you think
that are shooting
you got to you got to check yourself
well look look the Hall of Fame is rare
ER it's a Hall of Fame because very few
people are allowed
in very few people are allowed in and
you and I know you and I know that like
there are certain people were not even
you just you go like this so khabib you
go like this DUS pu you go like this you
know um there are a lot of people like
that um Charles
olera you see what I mean most
submissions of all time most submission
finish of all time and lightweight
champion yes Charles oliv's in you got
to put him in right have to yeah I think
that's what I mean I think you know
who's definitely in without even
thinking about it um Alain uh no uh not
yet um but uh that guy volkanovski
volovski huh that guy you know that guy
volkanovski you got any questions about
that yeah right so some of the stuff is
like that we know we just know St Bay's
Hall of Famer ROM Hall of
Famer Andre lski Hall of Ste Hall of
Famer EAS verom easily Hall of Famer
Hall of Famer Kane Hall of Famer Kane
Hall of Famer
um so you know what I'm saying you don't
you don't you don't have to hesitate in
my opinion this is gonna this shitty but
in my opinion if you don't have to
hesitate if you don't have to hesitate
no there has to be an argument cuz of
it's complicated like Justin Gate's
complicated it's complicated we
shouldn't be but you look at like all
right cuz Brock Lesnar's complicated
well no no no no look at me Brock's
complicated what he did for the sport is
complicated getting in oh wow I can't
let you in oh wow and I'm sorry about
that and I hate it I don't like this job
but I got to keep the you don't want us
run Hall of Fame everybody I got to keep
the air RI they're like you allowed CM
Punk in the Hall of Fame like yeah big
deal yeah that's what happen he never
won if you and I if you and I were
running this the thing and we had dinner
with them the night before we'd be like
know I like him so much we're the wrong
guys you guys voted yourselves I'll tell
you who gets in in my opinion Michael
bisbing in your opinion in everybody's
[__] opinion you're driving me nut
you see what I'm saying no that Michael
bis's a shoe that's what I mean you
don't have to think about it the the you
get mad the Rosa parts of British
fighting you get mad when I you get mad
when I even hint that there being that's
what saying that's insane no I'm saying
of course that's why he's in it Mighty
Mouse 100% there are no the Hall of Fame
is for people where if I say if I go
like this to you and I go Michael bising
you what shut the [__] what you say
you're mad at me yeah that's Hall of
Fame if we have to have a discussion
this is where Daniel cormet he's got a
point on listen Daniel Daniel not us
like he's he he's there the only two
guys on the outside getting into
you f I did but still but DC's right on
this but there's other ones where it's
they're on the fence and you got to you
got to talk about it just like the MLB
does you know you have to talk about it
you got to talk about it you have to
talk about it there are certain people
that cuz you got to remember too there's
different there's like what Kimbo Slice
did arguably the most famous man to
fight gets to the
UFC Hall of Famer or no see see what
happens ch's resume see what happens
this is the last one
cuz right away I go of course then
inside I go who'd he be this is [__]
because you can't be a prisoner of the
moment because also are we saying CHS an
incident Hall of Famer because he's
relevant spider spider gets in of course
right so so I I say to you you go you go
you say [__] you we don't we don't have
a conversation right but we don't have
conversation have some like Cha's a
conversation because you would go yeah
of course ch's so famous and he's the
man now right he put the he put well he
put UFC in many ways everybody started
talking about UFC with ch sun is one of
those guys like Conor McGregor who is
such a powerful interesting take
personality wow cuz it's a tough one
it's a tough one but when I say that
name you go like this I went absolutely
and then I went wait a second let me
think about who he's
beat um I got to keep R he beat
vanderlay he beat Shogun keep going down
he beat bisbing he beat Brian Stan he
beat Nate he beat Okami Dan Miller Paulo
filo and then Paulo filo's WC
days and that was to the WC Championship
okay look if you want if you want to
really keep the the Hall of Fame God CH
fought the who who ch's Hall of Famer is
he yes is he dude hold on let's go over
his wind you piece of [__] CH listen no
I love CH son I love CH sonen let me ask
you this is Rampage Hall of Famer
Bonafide Hall of Famer
you don't know fighting no hold on I
didn't say anything Rampage I didn't say
anything let's let me ask you this hold
on let me just finish let me absolutely
okay hold on Rampage Jackson Hall of
Famer Vander Silva Hall of Famer Shogun
Bonafide Hall of Famer Hall of Famer if
you bring Pride into it not if you bring
the UFC into it he's great in the UFC
was he got to go through his record your
piece of [__] hold on hold on so got
Rampage you got vanderlay you got Shogun
three Hall of Famers bisbing Hall of
Famer Brian Stan Tito Ortiz 100% of
course right tto Ortiz 100% for what he
did Okami Dan Miller Nate markart so he
has three Hall of Famer wins and he's a
champion in
WC I I think ch's are shoing you and I
we you and I love chel sonen because we
love CH sonen I'm going based off stats
here now vanderlay is a better argument
yeah yeah yeah his best win was over
yeah he's not getting Keith Jordine he's
not getting he's not getting in the UFC
Hall no he's not getting in we agree on
this okay yeah does it bother you he
lost to merco and I beat him does that
bother you cuz that I wouldn't put him
in the Hall of Fame just for that hold
on brenon Shaw beat a guy you couldn't
well you're his dick if you fight uh
vanderlay uh I'm putting all my money on
you because you're just so much bigger
and stronger he's got big problems with
you yeah I'm not going to stand there
and baying with him uh you might you
might you might no I
wouldn't um yeah fander is not getting
the uall fame I got to keep there's
gonna be a pride Wing So that that
Rampage is definitely Hall of Fame
shogun's definitely the Hall of Fame
Rampage Rampage is a bona go to
Rampage but you're bringing in are you
bringing in Pride or are you bringing in
UFC was a champion right I'm just
bringing in UFC I too yeah well there's
a Wing for Pride though now we're
talking about wings okay so we going
talking about practice okay you talking
about wings so so so so so so are you
bringing in Pride because in Rampage
Jackson you got to give it up would
let's go to rampage's oh he lost three
tough ones keep going
down so he beat L Macha beat vanderlay
Silva beat Keith Jordine lost a forest
beat Dan Henderson that's a big one beat
Chuck Liddell yeah he's amazing I
remember Chuck in his prime left hand I
remember it very well his prime to win
the the championship yeah now chuck
chuck is another
hey
man gosh you [__] chuck chuck is in
the Hall of Fame I will fight you over
that I'll fight you right now I I want
Chuck you go down the Chuck Lane then
you got go down go down the Randy
Couture Lane no no no we're not going
down no Randy Cur of Sho in oh Chuck has
better numbers R see but that's how this
is this is where we get let's just say
the committee the committee and I'm part
of the committee we look at overall body
can I just say this let's just do this
for ourselves let me just do it just
because we have to because you have to
there's respect and Legacy and there's
also Trailblazers Tito Ortiz Hall of
Fame saying because are Trailblazers I'm
talking about just their contribution to
the sport well then that's my argument
with Kimbo no no no well then you're
arguing out the window it's not no it's
not oh my god he has F Kimo hasn't
fought enough lost everything he sucks
don't ever bring him up again I love him
good God bless in peace rest in peace
good man but he's not don't don't put
him in when you talking about
Trailblazers Kimo slice was the most
famous
for fighting no no no
no for a second thead for a second I'm
talking about real athletes who really
were you're talking about body of work
which would include outside the UFC
contributions yes kimbo's that Chell yes
Leota Macha yes brought karate into this
whole different thing um uh Tito Ortiz
100% again all these guys belt holders
at one point um
uh uh Rampage Jackson you got to put
these guys in the Hall of Fame you just
said you wouldn't put ramp well no I
said I can I can I get then vanderlay is
a Pioneer too if you're doing that no in
Pride he was he was the graci killer but
I I'm not when he got in the UFC it
became a disaster he never became
Champion bring up Chuck Liddell's record
this is an awful
conversation Chuck liell is somebody's
got to be the gatekeeper his first
ballot Hall of F I know he is but forget
about those last ones keep going scroll
down CH how dare you all right 21 and
n
uh I'm just he knocked out Alistar over
in Pride no I'm not talking about Pride
we but no he was bouncing between
talking about wings we're talking about
no no no no hold on you got to has to
calculate in because that Dana White was
his manager let him go over to Pride
knock Alistar out and come back okay so
that should count towards Hall of Fame
record
count look Chuck Liddell um again you
just his contribution to the sport and
his legendary status and and you got to
put him in I I I'm not going to say no
there's no argument yeah no the truck's
an easy one you got to just but you got
to take away that but but Tru an easy
one so so so he fought a little too long
maybe yeah that's but that doesn't
that's all right it doesn't go up go up
to the to the to the Michael Jordan
you're can keep out of Hall of Fame
because he played for the Wizards go go
back up please for a sec um up or down
no up I want to to see what his ultimate
record was no go go the overall no the
overall chin there you go 21s nine
losses 1 2 3 4 5 6 seven of those losses
were when he was at the end of his
career from 2007 to 2008 mhm H so he was
in his prime in 2007 kind of and then
when he lost Rashad is when he went
downhill so one two four of his seven
losses or nine losses when he was out of
his Prime and older mhm 21 wins though
dude in his prime 21 he's the Bonafide
Hall of Fame this stupid argument he's
in the Hall of Fame easily easily
everyone no one's going to tell you no y
Chuck lell Le
Mach
dude committee with the committee let me
bring him up right off the bat My head
goes yes I know well we had there's an
emotional component what about Wonder
Boy never a Bel hold uh Pioneer though
God damn that's a good question Pioneer
though Fabian okay so again toward the
end we don't want to talk about no but
before that I beat Chael javil Calo is
tough vtor B for ER
canders CB doway Gard mousasi
I don't know I mean Dan Henderson Ryan
Bader Randy Couture I cornered Randy for
that
fight Shogun the classic Shogun the KO
of Rashad Thiago Silva Tito Ortiz yes
he's a Hall of Famer yeah yes
yeah 12
losses we're going over losses then
cowboy and J follow Sports what's your
criteria a mean bouncer at a nightclub
man I'm just trying to keep the air rare
I'm trying trying to be these guys are
rare air dude they are rare air but
you're holding these losses against well
26 wins only 12 losses is is uh is a
conversation look at Randy Couture's
record if you if you go based off losses
you can't hold those Captain America
don't ever bring him up again in the IDE
he's he's in the Hall of Fame well he
hates us but yeah yeah well hopefully
Chuck and Randy are already in there
though of course they are they this is
no argument
GSP is in the Hall of Fame too right GSP
is in the see what happens when you say
that we all go what it's like guing if
Tom Brady's in the NFL but this is what
I'm saying is the Hall of Fame for those
extreme winners so we're only like five
people in we don't have a business yeah
you know what maybe you're piece of [__]
now ry's 1911 that's a salty record
oh yeah again I I there are certain
people that were pioneer in the sport
that put the sport on the map and
they're in the Hall of Fame and at the
time had huge wins in his prime huge
that's Randy Couture that's that's Tito
Ortiz that's Chuck Liddell that's VOR B
vtor you're not going to love V buer in
the Hall of Fame the youngest
what wow I can I get a second bring up
VOR I'm just trying to get a second I
can't even get one I'll die on the hill
like Kimbo should be Hall of Fame I
can't don't no he can't be in the Hall
of Fame he can be part of the
history he's on the wing 26 14 the guys
that have been fighting for a long time
are going to have some losses I'm not
allowing it I'm not dude he beat Dan hon
Luke rockold Michael bisbing Bonafide
Hall of Famers great Anthony Johnson
Anthony Johnson yeah aiyama yeah Rich
Franklin Hall of Famer Matt linlin Up
For Debate storyed career man storyed
career but a lot of Alistar those guys
are huge I he's going to lose to Alistar
of course but yeah I um you beat Randy
Hall of
Famer Randy in his prime you put Randy
in the Hall of Fame oh I got you he's a
hall ofer two doctor stop he's a hall
ofer two doctor stoppages he's a Hall of
Famer
yeah you you putting him in 100% okay
VOR bfor you're insane no I didn't say
anything I'm not saying anything I I'm
not even allowed to [__] take a
minute I can't even take a minute to
figure things out now Leo Macho knocks
Ran So then then if vor's in then you
got to put Leo MAA in do he beat him but
he beat an older Randy you got remember
when they fought no that the same energy
you had with Charles our boy our boy VOR
beat
leot no VOR
is beat yeah leot beat VOR so you got to
put him in I
think it's a weird game to play it's
tough It's a weird game to play one more
tough one for you aler over in the UFC
take out Pride K1 alar over in the UFC
go to go to him chin absolutely not no
abwe champion of the world no B Brock
Lesnar uh okay kicked him in the [__]
stomach yeah okay I think that's the
only time I can remember him winning
that so not in the UFC I can't do it you
heard of Sergey pavlovich tough right
gotten
starched yeah Fabo verdum beat him
fabricio's first boutle Hall of Famer
Mark hunt he beat Mark hunt Andre rovski
is Mark hunt in the Hall of Fame uh JDS
Roy Nelson Stephan stru Frank May Brock
Lesnar uh JDS
yes I I you know I'm have to go through
the criter I'm let too many guys you let
a guy [__] man I mean you hey hey are
you are you the guy in January 6 open
the gates and let everybody in cuz I
mean this is not January you know what
everybody come the [__] on in it's the
Hall of Fame
wooo is like [__] trying he's like on
the Titanic trying to stop all the
[__] no DC's is the white girl the
one white girl that got shot in the face
trying to keep people yeah holy [__] uh
yeah unbel well I hear JDS like maybe
confirmation bias I'm like yeah
absolutely
JDS I I don't know what to do anymore
with you it's
like I I guess everybody say what about
Roy
Nelson never a heavyweight
champion Ultimate Fighter Champion I
don't think there's anybody tougher I
don't think there's anybody who can who
back in his prime could take all the
punishment yeah but does that get you in
Hall of Fame God [__] I hate this God
no no no 24 wins 20 losses no I can't no
no no no no well but if you're going off
longevity Ronda Rousey she didn't fight
very long bu she's in the Hall of Fame
the now we're talking about branches
she's in the female Branch but we're
going just based off UFC fighters
because she's the Hoist graci of female
Fighters she she's she's an all of Fame
there's but then you'd have to put Gina
Carano in um she's R before Rhonda yeah
but and then you have to put cybor
changed everything Rhonda changed
everything she put women on the map in
fighting she is the ultimate Pioneer
she'll be she'll be she'll go down to
history as as a feminist icon yeah she's
ho gra yes she's incredible she's more
than that because she she showed men
what women were capable of she
demonstrated the same skill and ferocity
certainly ferocity and desire to win
while being feminine so Ronda Rousey is
is no she only had eight fights in the
UFC doesn't matter a goddess she had
eight fight trazer she she she went six
and two in the UFC without even thinking
about it you and I put her in the Hall
of Fame without even thinking about it
and guess who else is in the Hall of
Fame Amanda Nunes
oh yeah well yeah no [__] I'm putting
I'm put about Rose namun Nam junis right
now no no belt holder you piece of [__]
you [__] it's [__] tough you're
well you're giving me [__] I now now now
Rose just without even thinking belt
holder [__] unreal it we're doing the
female upset upset we're doing the
female Wing Yan and jenic upsets her who
was unbeatable for the longest time
and and I got a question for you is she
in the Hall of Fame you [__]
chauvinist piece of [__] now we're
talking about feem like yeah yeah yeah
WNBA I hope that thing get I hope they
have to Lop your [__] arm off I
really do I'm going to call you righty
throbbing my arm is throbbing are you
taking antibiotics no a py that's bad
yeah I know is it does it look bad yeah
it's not good it shouldn't be what else
you got chin
seeping theall Fame question is fun
though huh that's it though huh so what
you
want they're in the female
Wing man man I don't know about you bro
you want vanderlay silver you want Al
now this where gets tough cuz the NFL
doesn't have a female Wing right the NBA
doesn't have a female Wing but we got we
do have have so exactly then the female
Wing now if we're talking about fighting
overall take out Sexes none of them make
except Ronda and Amanda not fair that's
it no no we're putting them there's a
the women had eight fights Jim Miller
has
50 8 to 50 dude I don't care we're
talking about you're talking about the
separate Wing now no you're talking
about practice no we're not you're
talking about practice no dude there's a
female Hall of Fame yeah there is and
then okay who do you want in go ahead
that's a little easier to make cuz it's
new no dude it's like if there's a slap
fight that's like if there's a slap
fight Hall of Fame it's new it's new no
dude it's new I hate you right now no
bro it's new come on man so that
Wolverine guy you're in the Hall of Fame
it's new respectful it's new be
respectful it's new it's like everybody
do get Oscars no no no no you got to
look at effort and division they're in
they're fighting other women there's a
reason there's female sports male Sports
correct and and there's a Wing for that
no I don't like he's saying Wing has a
wing don't they have a mail no asteris
here come on no there's a Wing for no no
no listen to me there's a Wing your arm
is seeping it's oh it's throbbing dude
and it's
hot now you have you have bad you have a
bad infection you're going to die all
right you have to go to the doctor for
that by the way have you been to the
doctor for it for my arm my head no okay
my head's worse my head's worse are you
putting antibotic ointment on that yes
that's not true I put NE spor on it okay
that counts more I put the spray that my
kids use yeah let's go ahead I did
myself dab that I did it myself yeah you
got to dab that up my head's worse than
my arm yeah I'm out of it I keep
I can't keep stop talking about wings
yeah you I'm concussed Wings yeah you're
going to blame it all on your concussion
yeah they come for me for this Wings
it's it's tough because I as I say it I
know some of these people and I don't
want them to get mad at me but it's like
too late no way too late if I'm a I
wonder what they would say I wonder if
they would say I should be in it well
like you you wouldn't put sugar Shan in
which he's going to be a Bonafide Hall
of Famer we think but you wouldn't put
him in right now it's too new well yeah
because he's currently fighting I don't
think the conversation is not guys who
are in currently fighting I don't want
to have that we just had the
conversation about Jim Miller for 30
minutes you piece of dumb ass still
fighting still fighting
yes it's a it's a dumb you AR concussed
you piece of dumbass you piece of
dumbass but I mean Jim Miller is a very
very hard one for me now he's in yeah
yeah I know dude everybody's in with you
January 6 everybody's in man just open
it on up get on in [__] over here
come on in Rays let's go bring it in
listen it's a fun combo though it's a
fun combo Misha Tate it's a fun combo
what else you got chin she's a Pioneer
pioner back to your point though the
female Wing she's
in hot hot all Fame Hall of Famer first
well pance answer too yeah yeah you got
we got to get way more strict with with
the Hall of Fame what do you sonas
you're in sports what do you think
what's criteria what is criteria for
Hall of Fame for UFC
for just UFC so new it's also a lot
newer NFL has UFC is tough because of
how new it is you know and think about
female fighting's even newer female
fighting is like 10 years old football
football different now we're talking
about but you decades Bubba okay and so
many more people play that so so how
many people get into the Hall of Fame
every year in football in I
don't um that's a great question what is
cu guys don't get in the Hall of Fame
even if they're all Pro ah okay so well
there you go no it's it's been around
longer I don't give a [__] what it's
been around it depends on what you want
real hall of fame or do you want some
[__] there's more positions but do
you want a real like a kicker in the
Hall of Fame is different than a
quarterback but I mean they're
quarterbacks in the NFL in the Hall of
Fame that have not four to eight only
each year out of all those
players I mean think about baseball
think about basketball living guys on a
team to be a Hall of
Famer
there's guys that would blow your mind
that aren't in the Hall of Fame bet blow
your mind oh I bet like who I bet I I
wish I had a reference blow your mind
but yeah so you you don't want to be
that strict so you don't really believe
in a real Hall of Fame for the UFC you
know what you do you you you the one you
grade on a [__] curve dude oh yeah
I'm and so do I yeah I know and shame on
us but CH son is on the see I I allowed
my good friend CH in the Hall of Fame
you didn't I love the guy he's not show
he not coming to show no I'm probably
going to put CH in backck now's
contribution to the sport is so keep
saying that anytime you're on the fence
you're like there's contribution how
much of a cont commit doesn't give a
[__] you're the one I'm just saying well
this why you got to have a committee
well well how much do you do not let
Brian on that Comm how much do you how
much weight do you put contribution the
guy and that that's my argument for
Kimbo SCE UFC when you say UFC people
think of CH son like you they're not you
can't separate that's because he's a
figure outside of fighting but be when
he was fighting he was like nowh near
this way bigger now yeah but what got
him to the game in the dance talking
[__] not winning fights man but he's in
my hall of
fame he's in ch's in for his fighting so
talk talking [__] is is that's what you
just said no you just said it I didn't
rewind the tape rewind the tape you just
said for talking [__] not winning fights
he's a first battle Hall of Famer hey
bro he's already in my hall of fame so
talking [__] is is a criteria we should
get him on the phone right now I want to
talk to him call him call him right now
I'm say hey CH should you be in the Hall
of Fame this is a great call call CH you
want to call Rampage next I'm afraid
afraid I'm afraid of Rampage I love him
but I don't want I don't want to insult
Rampage because I I'm a huge fan of
Rampages in every way just not enough to
be in the Hall of Fame I don't I'm not
getting into that conversation my fault
is to put Rampage in the Hall of Fame
because of his again his
contribution you calling him mhm I'm
giving my heads up though that he's
live
good did he I would love to get his I'd
love to have him weigh in on this we got
to start having people zoom
in yeah we're probably going to start
having brother what's up brother hey I I
text you you're live on the air so me
and Brian we're going over if Jim Miller
should be in the Hall of Fame and then
we started going down a list of all the
guys that we think should be in the Hall
of Fame and then we're at you right now
and I said you're a Bonafide Hall of
Famer Brian says I let too many people
in I didn't say that ch ch give me this
phone CH there's an emotional attachment
we have for you we love you so I I I
said about you I said you are your
contribution to the sport is
immeasurable and and you just can't
you're you're synonymous with the UFC so
we have to take in whether whether the
the ability to talk [__] and and create
that kind of color in the Hall of Fame
but also had some big wins see what he
thinks Brian you know what you think see
what he thinks criteria for Hall of Fame
first of all does Jim Miller get in does
Jim Miller get
in boy I I I I believe so but I do
understand your point even if even if it
brings me into that which is um I mean
what is the criteria right like like if
you're the first if you're innovator if
you do anything Innovative that sticks
around for the sport you probably belong
in the Hall of Fame and as far as Miller
goes you know I I don't know because I
don't think he's done that's what's so
exciting I mean here he is at 40 some
years old and we've never had a
situation like this Brendon we have
private talks where guys reach this age
but privately we know how they reached
that
age subst that's not the case with
Miller CH I want to call you on my phone
because it's it's better it's the sound
is better than this um yeah it's way
louder so hold on just answer the phone
CU I want to I really want to get your
take on this this is important all right
I'll answer the phone okay answer the
phone hold
on all
right ja here there he is all right
buddy uh that's way better okay so so so
Jim Miller yes well you're talking about
a guy who fought a lot you're you've got
uh can you bring up his yeah ch ch real
quick this is my argument for Jim Miller
because he's at the most competitive
division in the world at 55 and he's
never miss weight he's hasn't Miss
weight in over 50 fights he's made it
all every time he's made weight at 40
the longevity I would put him the Hall
of Fame for the wins and the the
competition and never missing weight I I
don't disagree I don't disagree I'm I'm
just with you guys to add to the
conversation like there are some wings
of the Hall of Fame that have opened up
over time that I never would have
thought of like I mean they put uh a
trig and Hughes in there for for round
number two of their first fight I mean
that seemed a little bit complicated to
me yeah I kind of felt like hey man
you're in the Hall of Fame where you
aren't and so then you got finishes in
the Hall of f or or it got you know it's
one of those situations where Miller is
definitely in unchartered territories
not to mentioned he's doing it clean
yeah I mean this really is amazing the
fact that he's winning fights uh getting
fights the fact that he's finishing
fights I think there's another
conversation Brenda which is just for
consideration but how big of fights was
he in like like being able to deal with
pressure and you know being able to
overcome is a really big deal sometimes
you know even Miller called for fights
at 300 he called for three different
fights and they were all undercard
fights I just thought it was surprising
I'm saying he he's never really those
big fights but he fights that's for sure
yeah that's what I'm saying is like how
many title fights did he how many titles
did he fight for what kind of
competition did he have Let's Get to You
CH you you know let's just be honest
where do you think if are you are you in
the Hall of
Fame yes I would I would myself in the
Hall of
Fame yeah BBE the tough one understand
like that's the most um most coveted
thing that we have in our sport largely
because you don't get in it the way I
just you get a title fight the way I
just did coming out and saying I'm the
guy give me that would get you a title
fight the Hall of Fame doesn't work that
way you know you got to earn it and then
you're being judged by your peers but
there's I don't know how many guys I
believe four guys in the Hall of Fame
right now that I've beaten so some of
which I finished so I mean in all
fairness and Brian one thing one thing
that did happen to me just to look back
at my career when I do look at well that
really wasn't very fair I was the first
guy to ever be ranked at two different
weight classes simultaneously there was
push back how is he ranked in the top 10
at 85 and 205 yeah it had never been
done before um I only bring to you I
fought over three different weight
classes I fought World Champions at
heavyweight at 205 and at
sometimes that does get he Dro some
trash and then he couldn't beat the guy
yeah but the guy was Fedor nobody could
beat him tell me won 85 pound of the
tried to beat him like yeah I do feel
like a little bit of of that story gets
lost of the 11 world champions I fought
I beat eight of them I mean not not for
nothing I didn't always beat him on the
right time when they had the belt but I
beat him nonetheless that's big yes I
think it'd be hard to say I don't
believe I don't belong in the hall agree
what about Nate Diaz we're putting you
in Nate Diaz how about Nate Diaz
absolutely I agree yeah absolutely I
agree I agree I agree the contributions
there are very different you know I know
at one point he was kind of batting like
500 but his contributions were were very
different they very meaningful and
significant a salord you know how you
relate with the public and it is a big
deal I mean if you're if you're batting
500 but you're only selling out Arenas
in main event fights and that's what
Diaz did yeah versus you know you've won
more fights than anybody but me right
here cha son a huge fan not trying to be
condescending I could not name five
opponents that you've ever had it's a
little bit of a different spot in all in
all fairness it really is y yep yep well
said uh now Nick Diaz for me isn't even
a like he's in for me I what do you
think of Nick Diaz of course course
largely for the same
reason stupid question there are guys
where we don't even have to we don't
even hesitate right we don't even
hesitate we're like Leo what about
here's another one how about Leota Macha
yes I would say yes and and again
because of the contributions I remember
a t-shirt that was made and it it sold
out in three days when Mach became
champion and it simply said karate is
back and it had a picture of Mach but it
was a big deal man we were laughing at
karate we were laughing at you know some
of these aidos and karate some of these
big names we heard these big disciplines
we've heard of and MAA is the one that
said not so fast I do it differently my
father did it differently my brothers do
it differently we sacrificed we train
and their story was really hard I they
were getting up before school and had to
do workouts as soon as school was done
father had him back in the gym I me he
was drinking pee there was some stuff
was very weird but the was there so so
so the discipline was there 100% last
one last one last one this is going to
be a tough one Brock
Lesnar yes Brock Lesnar would go in off
off of uh the kind of attraction that he
was not necessarily because of his skill
like Brock Lesnar does not have a black
belt in anything and that includes
wrestling I know they love to tell the
story about what a great amateur
wrestler he was that isn't true but he
was effective and he won and the same
thing goes with with martial arts like
he wasn't a great
but he was effective but I can't let him
in ch with eight fights I can't let him
in with eight fights and and that and
like I I'm sorry but this is what
happens if we've got to if we're going
to start talking about contribution you
have to weigh whether contribution where
is contribution happen how how much
weight does that hold over actual wins
he did beat Shane Carn he did beat Frank
Mir he did beat Randy cador did beat
Heath Herring that's kind of it though
it's kind of it you know he loses came
Velasquez and at the end of the day he
only fights how many times eight times
in the UFC that's just not I don't know
can I throw one thing at you too because
uh like when I look back in my own
career it wasn't all Moonlight canoes as
much as I'm telling you 11 world
champions and I beat them eight of them
like but there's a way to compete and
when you brought up the Diaz brothers by
example even if they're going 500 when I
watch them I admire the way they compete
they will grind it out till the final
minute I was I did a little better job
of knowing when my toast was burnt and
you and and it's different and you don't
like to talk about that but it is a very
true thing like there's guys that I
could I could look at and admire because
of the way that they competed big nog
would go on that list just by example uh
people say that about Justin gatei and
it's very true about the kind of grit
that he has so some guys with that kind
of grit don't have the greatest records
but boy fellow Fighters admire them yes
but is that is that but is that criteria
to get into to the Hall of Fame you got
Daniel corm saying well well you got
Daniel corm saying Jim Miller probably
shouldn't be in the Hall of Fame I
understand that
argument but because we do have to
ultimately like when I say Max hallay
you go 100% when I say Justin gatei you
go I got to think about that a little
bit just because of longevity and and
where he's been he's an interim belt
holder that's big but you know you know
what I'm saying so for me it's a tough
one isn't it I will tell you Daniel T me
was a little bit easier to to give a nod
to until he got in there there is
something about those guys get in they
get up in the LOF they try to pull the
ladder up behind them and all of a
sudden the criteria gets a lot harder
and I watch Tito Ortiz do that Tito
Ortiz was complaining about who was
getting in it's like Tito when you were
Champion they had 18 guys signed when I
tried to become Champion they had 650
guys signed like it wasn't the same
belt interesting that's very inter a
great record very nice Named Dave man
Carlos Newton had his time I'm just
sharing like there was different times
there was times to be Champion he listen
I was there the day they made Jose Aldo
and Ronda Rousey champion and neither
had ever competed in the Octagon yet
that's right I was there the night they
woke Matt Hughes up and informed him he
was the champion of the world like we've
had some things happen that are you know
that that that do raise a little bit of
an eyebrow and I think when you come
down to the way guys competed I mean
Brennan and I are both pretty tough uh
you know pretty tough critics but there
are guys that we would damn that guy man
I wish I had more of what he had I think
it would I just think it should be
considered over record yeah man I mean
this is all I love I love your take on
it I love your take on it so it's a
tough one I'm glad I'm not on the uh I'm
glad I'm not on the committee because I
I I I emotion plays a factor all these
things play a factor the real question
is what what is the heaviest for you
last question when it comes to getting
somebody into the Hall of Fame what is
the one overriding consideration is it
is it
championships H for me it would be could
he draw I mean that would be the big
deal if really could he draw that's so
then would he put Kimbo in no Kimbo you
can't put Kimbo in are you putting Kimbo
in I'm saying
no CH I love that your phone messed up
and you're talking about [__] look at my
goddamn arm dude what the hell you got
to go to the we just lose him oh you
there
buddy it's breaking up I think your your
your reception's bad chill can you hear
me oh guys I'm sorry oh no we got you
now we got we got you now the spirit of
Kimbo I'm trying not to move and hey I
want I want by the way when I say
popular I wouldn't say that that's
that's the overwhelming I'm just saying
there are some guys that were Champions
at different times where if you threw
their name out
people is
a ultim
cont okay it's an ultimate popular
contest you're still breaking up okay
listen I'm sorry listen this was very
very good we're going to have you zoom
in one of these days soon because I love
this I love your take on this stuff it's
[__] great appreciate it can you guys
hear me now because I do have one point
I'd like to make yeah yeah we can hear
you okay in the sport of rodeo and I
realize how different that is but I grew
up in Rodeo my father was a cowboy but
in the sport of they have a national
finals and they will Crown a world
champion that day but just so you
understand you could get bucked off your
horse and still be world champion that
day how's that work well in Rodeo they
will look at it over the course of a
year 365 days whoever made the most
money is the world champion and when you
okay Judah will go over the the course
of of a year they will have different
class A tournaments you total of the
points that you scored from those
tournaments so for a longest time the
person representing our country at the
Olympic Games in Judo is whoever's dad
had the most money whoever's Dad could
get them to Paris and get them to Tokyo
and get these points at these
tournaments let just share for you this
seem to came up with pro wrestlers who's
the best pro wrestler ever and the
answer is Hulk Hogan why he didn't know
the difference between a wrist lock and
a wristwatch but he drew the most money
so there is a piece of it there's a
popularity contest the same thing goes
with politicians who's the best poit
whoever they like the most yeah yeah
yeah that's this is this is interesting
I know we we hate to admit that that's a
part of it we hate to admit that we
can't see through that but we have to if
you were doing something no matter how
well you're doing it if we have a piece
of ingredients that the audience didn't
want but but but CH you you would not
say that about baseball football or
basketball you'd have to look at Stats
you got to look at Stats so if you if
you want to have a different Hall of
Fame criteria for the UFC than you do
for the big three sports or even hockey
uh the big four you you're you're that's
fine but just know that then then then
the Hall of Fame you run the risk of
making the Hall of Fame in the UFC not
as uh not holding the same kind of
weight you really just do so you got to
be either [__] or you or you
just open the gates to a lot of people
sure I hear what you're saying I hear
what you're saying it's tough hey it's
like anything in this sport though
fellas don't forget we fiercely adhere
to whatever rules we make up on the spot
that is one thing that is consistent
from 1993 to
2024 it's a good point
whatever Jorge mazal 100% in my book is
in the Hall of Fame okay what do you
think yeah yeah I I mean I would say yes
I would say yes and for a variety of
different reasons and even when his
record wasn't great if you at the guy
City he fought and you look at the way
he compete with those guys yeah that's
right we're losing you again buddy I'm
gonna I'm I'm gonna we're gonna we're
gonna Zoom you very
soon that was chill sunon awesome the
great take you got to go to the hospital
dude why it's really bad no it's fine is
it bad because it's still leaking no
it's bad like so urging care actually
doesn't look um it's just a scrap
infected it looked like it was just
bleeding yeah but I mean it's better to
do it now than because where it's at cuz
I keep rubbing is it actually throbbing
no no just put um put um neopor yeah put
NEOS sporn you're actually fine we do
not have a it's not pussing it's not P
there's no yeah he knows about that
stuff from well good old Uncle cha
chiming in he's the best but he said the
popularity contest but in my opinion
then okay it's going to be a different
kind of Hall of Fame than the Hall of
Fes that gave the Fame it's but the UFC
it has to be different because that is a
huge like in in football Timo is the
most famous guy in the planet but they
can't just play him or put him in the
Hall of Fame because he's most famous
the UFC it's such a big indicator of who
sells tickets and who's on Main cards if
you're popular yeah that's the a big
aspect of our sport so the Hall of Fame
the Hall of Fame has to represent
that yeah Fair ch's a smart dude man I
like a politician yep all right what do
you got Chen you guys want current
events we're at 125 right now oh okay is
are they is there any good ones or
obviously Trump winning the Iowa like
landow he's going to be president unless
they put him in jail yeah you prob stop
it there my arm's going to fall off yeah
dude dude try to go to the hospital nah
never all right I I got to get back to
the shop oh God damn it I got to go
train guys I got to get back to the mats
so uh I'd love to do this by the way
this weekend Phoenix Arizona come on now
Friday January uh 19th Saturday almost
sold out Saturday early show sold out
basically out yep then we got Sunday a
little light come on Sunday come on
Sunday January 21 7 o'clock let's do
this one show only on Sunday for you
Louisville comedy clubs Chang to March
uh January 31 February 31 March 1 I'm
not going to be doing that there yeah so
there we go see you soon all right kids
I'm in Nashville January 25th zany one
night only in Nashville then Austin
Texas at the Vulcan January 26 27th
that's a Friday Saturday get some
special guests uh so Nashville's the
25th Austin 26 27th fight campaign this
Saturday Joseph Rogan Joey Diaz Eddie
Bravo myself make sure you tune in 7 PM
Pacific on Joe Rogan JRE YouTube and
it'll be uploaded to Spotify all right
kids love you chel a Hall of Famer told
you there it is we're out